I know you guys been waiting for a long
time for me to come here there has been
some threats car DB was forced to call
off a performance in Indianapolis
Indiana on Tuesday due to a quote threat
against the artist
according to police press press press
car D don't need bulk press the show was
postponed just an hour prior to the
scheduled start time the rapper took to
Twitter to apologize to her fans and
explained what went down unfortunately
there was a security threat that is
currently under investigation right now
my safety and your safety first Indiana
I know that you guys been bought these
tickets for a long time I know you guys
been waiting for a long time for me to
come here and my makeup artist she
packing my hair I respect her head
there has been some threats that the
Indianapolis Metropolitan Police
Department further explained the
situation on Twitter quote this evening
there was a scheduled concert at Bankers
Life we were notified of an unverified
threat to the artist and the artist
cancelled this evening's concert there
is no immediate threat to public safety
this not an active incident ongoing
investigation the venue Bankers Life
Fieldhouse announced the postponement at
6:20 4 p.m. the concert was scheduled to
kick off at 7:00 p.m. on Wednesday cardi
took to Twitter to share more
information about the security issue
writing I was literally getting my
makeup when police and security from
venue got a threat tip in a series of
tweets in response to one user who said
cartee should simply quote sweep the
venue and move on she further explained
why postponing the show was the right
call to make I'm a mother
my safety come first adding I even left
the state ASAP because I ain't takin no
chances cardi continued to defend
herself in a third tweet writing if a
gotta go a [ __ ] gotta go
[Music]
[Applause]